hi this is John Roca for Collider
talking with Adriana Vanessa and Yvette
monorail from the new film Rambo last
blood I absolutely love this movie
either I want to start with you because
you are acting royalty for a lot of us
in the Latino community yes but I wanted
to ask you what was your experience or
knowledge of the Rambo series before you
were involved in this movie obviously I
so ramble Marcelin in the eighties and
then I saw the last one okay for because
I want to to see the journey of the hero
you know how is this growing up and how
is it there 7 so suing Teddy Oromo for
creciendo
yeah his inner journey yes yes I really
intersting that yeah because I will
receive these run for 10 years later
right and I wanted to see this man
mm-hmm
at the eyes and have compassion for that
yeah for his journey and what he
struggled with as a soldier dealing with
PTSD right event this is a very
difficult role for a young actress to
play you get run through the ringer in
this movie we don't want to spoil
anything but certainly you go on quite a
journey both emotionally and physically
yourself what was your preparation like
when you got involved with the project
for this well when I got involved with
the project I did obviously watch all
the Rambo movies and I also for a lot of
nights that I was shooting I was
watching documentaries that you know the
one sex trafficking what women went
through what they were feeling how like
why they stayed I just wanted to know
just because I was put in that situation
for so long in the movie I really wanted
to understand so yeah and I also rode
horses horses that was the happy part
right a little yeah
that was in a really dark state of mind
for a little bit but sure at the end of
the day it was really fun traveling to
Bulgaria in Tenerife that was so fun
yeah what was the greatest challenge you
had and what did you learn from your
experience being on the film my greatest
challenge I guess it would just be it's
kind of hard because I I do resonate
with the women who have gone through
these things it's hard it's easier to to
identify with with pain like that
emotional pain for me at least but the
challenge I guess it would just be at
first yeah when the script was changing
a lot so I guess like we would get new
scripts every day with little changes
and and the bulk of my scenes were with
Sylvester Stallone so at first I would I
got a little nervous but it was just a
technical thing yeah
Adriana you worked with Sylvester
Stallone what it was this experience
like for you as an actress working with
American royalty and an acting world and
Stallone for you well the beginning I
say oh my god what was it with him
and you know what I work with unnatural
mattresses not only in every kind of
places I try to see they work because I
want to know how is the the weight that
the doctor made this acting when I were
with him I discovered a wonderful
partner in stage I discovered at the
beginning of the first minute it really
this kind of connection because he saw
he saw you and you discover immediately
what happened inside yeah and it's
wonderful you know can you do it back to
them yes yeah not only happens but well
with no con todo el mundo no right now
with everybody yes but with him it was
beautiful yeah well that's beautiful to
watch on screen I enjoyed both you and
enjoyed the movie so thank you so much
Yvette Montreal and Adriana Barraza from
Rambo last blood go see this one it's
quite an experience